[Musique]
c'est la plus célèbre des parades
nuptiales
pour séduire la femelle le pan lui
présente ses plus beaux atours
[Applaudissements]
la crème peut atteindre un mètre et demi
de l'an
un bouquet de plus mme frêche qui tombe
et repousse chaque année le spectacle a
de quoi attirer le regard
[Musique]
mais il sollicite aussi des oreilles
quand il fait la roue le pan ne se
contente pas de montrer ses plumes et
les faire résonner
[Musique]
une démonstration qui peut répéter
pendant plusieurs minutes
[Musique]
l'exercice ne laisse rien au hasard
d'abord noise aussi brou pour déployer
sa traîne puis il agite les ailes et la
queue
le frottement du courte plume de
l'arrière-train sur le tuning fait
vibrer la traîne
la biologiste lowe's linda keen de
l'université de colombie-britannique et
ses collègues ont étudié en détail ce
mouvement ils ont constaté que les
plumes du paon entre en résonance elle
aussi à une fréquence qui leur est en
quelque sorte naturel ce qui permet à
l'oiseau d'amplifier leurs mouvements
avec un minimum d'effort
[Musique]
la fréquence de la libration avoisine
les 25 citations par seconde et produit
une sorte de vrombissements pour que
toutes les plumes de longueurs
différentes résonne à l'unisson la
structure du rachis la tige varient
ce mouvement rendu à thouars agite les
barbes répartis le long des plumes
les barbes en mouvement reflète encore
plus la lumière ce qui ajoute à l'effet
iridescent de la route les os elle reste
stable malgré la vibration plus lourde
est équipé de minuscules petits crochets
cette partie de la plume est conçue pour
rester en place
[Musique]
plus les plumes sont langues - ont
besoin d'être agitée rapidement pour
entrer en résonance pourtant les mâles
qui ont les plus grandes trail sont
aussi ceux qui ne se coule plus fort un
exercice épuisant
peut-être une façon pour les plus
vaillants de montrer leur endurance et
la qualité de leurs gènes ce spectacle à
la fois visuelle et sonore offre une
véritable séance d'hypnose
mais malgré les efforts du prétendant la
panne ne se laisse pas toujours séduire
si facilement
il semble que la taille de l'éventail ne
compte pas dans le choix de la femelle
[Musique]
elle optera plutôt pour le plumage le
plus éblouissant et peut-être le plus
doux freeney soir
[Musique]
m